congratulation being she i loved i
literally went through all oh okay what
made you want to delve into the swirls
in the first day well you know i don't
come from any sort of a wrestling
background in terms of fandom or
anything and carly my co-creator and i
we came across this documentary about
the women of flow looking back and that
was the thing that really first turned
us on to a that glow existed at all and
that it might be something that we could
tackle totally through the preparation
process for the show so in terms of
physically training and obviously
researching random mating for women in
eighties we all did wrestling training
together if you want to talk about it as
i do and we've trained before we started
shooting we trained for four and a half
weeks all together as a group of 14
women with Chavo Guerrero jr. of WWE and
Lucha Libre Fame and chavos uncle
actually was the original glow trainer
mando Guerrero trained the women from
the original grow that that you know
this show is based on which is such a
cool connection although Chavo was much
more mellow with us there are stories
about mando like choke holding choking
out in the girl leaper hold yeah until
she passed out set an example
Chavo never did anything like that with
us okay no but we trained for about four
and a half weeks and then also trained
throughout shooting for about four
months and then we also all kind of I
feel like immersed ourselves in eighties
movies and some like that our producers
gave us a little dip drive that had a
bunch of different 80s movies and glow
episodes on it and stuff like that I
found myself watching as I was trying to
look up movies that were nominated for
Oscars in 1985 as I felt like what would
roots be watching she'd really want to
watch those quality movies the things
she was striving to be a part of why do
you think it's just as important now
especially for women as it was in any
80s we've made many many strides but I
think you you know I was saying earlier
somebody that when we pitched the show
we we started our whole like
novels like penis is a great time for
women we're about to elect our first
female president we're so excited to you
know it feels like this is just the
right time to tell this story and I
think the reverse is completely true but
it's just yeah it's like we're a
terrifying time we don't know what's
going to happen it seems like stuff is
going to go really downhill but we
really feel like it's an important time
to tell these stories and it is nice to
see to to just be with all these women
I love the messages about you know
female independence and women defying
male stereotype limiting but it was her
just a really fun show yeah um for you
guys what was the funnest or that the
funniest scene to film for me does any
where I was walking you know like cuz I
see myself on the camera you know if I'd
look with those boots and just his
attitude you're driving that jeans big
dumb car I really liked our episode with
our first match I just thought it was so
weird and it really like because we're
on that table kind of watching it will
happen I think I realized how weird it
is I was like this is so weird oh and I
was announcing yeah oh yeah you're just
so charming and then there's like I
think emotionally that was the first
time the girls all come together and I
love I just love that episode of thing
it's so weird and then and then again
yeah the scene the scenes that me and
Mark had I think it was just really [ __ ]
there was just something real good and
contrasting about our characters being
together where I think it really
highlighted this sort of the cliches of
of characters that came out with each
other oh yeah you know I like that scene
where my ex-wife comes to get the dog
yeah yeah that was thank you brutal the
difficult awesome thank you so much